as it turns out the most incredible and
over-the-top headquarters is not in the
states at all but far away on the other
side of the world in the outskirts of
seoul in south korea that's right today
i'll be talking about the samsung
digital city the home base of one of the
largest entities in the world how big it
is
first off let's just try and establish
the sheer scale of the thing so having
heard the word digital city i'm willing
to bet a lot of you guys are already so
having heard the word digital city i'm
willing to bet a lot of you guys are
already scoffing i mean it can't really
be anything close to a city right well i
certainly hope you're someone who can
change their opinions because at nearly
400 acres of space while it may not be a
metropolis it is still bigger than many
towns and by employing nearly 35 000
employees it certainly has a population
of one and honestly being the kind of
company it is samsung needs all the
space it can get because unlike their
other competitors companies like google
and apple samsung doesn't just deal in
one kind of product not to mention the
sheer volume of stuff they produce puts
the other companies to shame i mean
during 2019 in the span of just one
quarter the company managed to sell 71.9
million smartphone units nearly more
than the next two companies combined
with huawei and apple selling 59.1
million and 36.4 million each and that's
only scratching the surface because as
you should know by now while most of us
only know samsung as the gigantic
information technology and consumer
electronics maker that's not the only
thing they do by a large margin ventures
and companies just to mention a few of
their ventures their subsidiary samsung
heavy is the world's second largest
shipbuilding company while their
construction divisions samsung
engineering and samsung cnt are both two
of the largest construction companies
out there and it's not even just tech
that they're good at as companies like
samsung life insurance specialise in
more economic ventures and seeing as
they're the 14th largest insurance
company in the world they seem to be
good at that too so with all of that on
the table it's no secret that the 84
year old company needs a pretty
substantial place to do all those
activities from and that brings us to
the actual site of the headquarters in
the ancient city of suwon just 30
kilometers south of seoul south korea's
capital while the main site is located
there the company has since expanded
into neighbouring cities like yeongin
and huasung which all combine to form
the area known as the samsung digital
valley but for the sake of briefness and
general entertainment needs today i'll
only be focusing on the main site based
in suwon now as i mentioned earlier the
total area covered by samsung's campus
is nearly 400 square kilometers 390 to
be precise and that area alone puts it
above international sites like the
vatican or monaco and as it turns out
size is not the only thing that the
samsung digital city has in common with
those cities because as it turns out the
city that the headquarters sits upon has
a bit of old history you see with its
roots in the early 8th century the city
of suwon is actually the last completely
walled city in the entire country and
the fact that samsung chose it to be
their headquarters is not a coincidence
because one of the reasons that samsung
preferred su-1 instead of seoul was that
during the korean war the huge walls
surrounding suwon helped protect the
samsung facilities inside by comparison
huge bits of their sight in seoul were
severely damaged and having experienced
that and wanting to avoid any such
problems in the future the company's
founder libyong chul decided to
officially move the company headquarters
from the capital city to suwon in 1951
which would later turn out to be the
decision that led to everything that
exists in the city today which brings me
to the next part of our video now that
the history lesson is over what exactly
is on site now well this is where stuff
gets really interesting because while
yes the company has its fair share of
offices labs and other corporate staff
there is a lot more that goes into
making the various cogs and gears of
south korea's largest company run
smoothly towers
but first the basic stuff on the campus
by far the most prominent buildings are
the four 38-ish story tall towers which
house a lot of the office space for the
day-to-day workers but besides those
four there are a dozen or so smaller
towers and over 130 buildings that
include everything else from labs and
offices to recreational facilities like
cafes and clubs and besides all those
there is also a kindergarten school for
the children of company employees and
even a guest house for visiting
researchers now one of the most asked
questions about the site is regarding
its cost i mean if apple can splurge out
5 billion on a campus less than half the
size of samsung's how much would this
thing even cost well the answer here is
that it's complicated you see unlike the
apple park or the googleplex or any of
the other corporate headquarters that we
know of the samsung digital city was not
made in a span of a few years instead
the campus has been growing and
expanding ever since the company first
set foot here but just in case you're
still curious it's estimated that the
maintenance cost of the campus tops
multiple million dollars every single
year so to say that it was probably not
cheap would be an understatement now
that i'm done with all of that stuff we
can take a look at some of the details
that make up the daily life around the
campus and that's where the digital city
really shines because while all the
largest information companies do have at
least some benefits for their employees
samsung operates at such a larger scale
it's far more impressive to see them
make an effort for their employees and
what makes it even more impressive is
just how much of it is there because if
i'm being honest the experience of being
a samsung employee at the digital city
is not only excellent it might just be
the best one out there the experience
first up there are campus cafeterias
that's right cafeterias with an s and
not only are there dozens of them
scattered around the place but there are
also supposed to be over 100 menus
serving all kinds of food day in day out
and best of all you eat at these places
for absolutely free and just in case you
feel like the food is not up to your
standard you are also welcome to visit
the international food franchises also
found on campus like everyone's favorite
mcdonald's or dunkin donuts apart from
food and drink many many more benefits
come from working on site these include
free transport across the campus free
medical checkups with the on-site staff
in case you suffer an emergency and free
transport in case you need to go to a
different doctor there's a kindergarten
school we already mentioned as well as 9
000 or so umbrellas ready to be handed
out to employees in case of sudden rain
as far as attractions go the place has
plenty of them too most famous among
them is probably the samsung innovative
museum which unsurprisingly showcases
the 90s year history of the company
besides that there are weekly events
which include everything from rock
concerts to fashion and talk shows and
then there are the clubs which help
employees maintain an interest in
activities outside of work so that
whether you're someone who likes to
paint or has always wanted to paraglide
you don't have to blame work for not
letting you chase your passions and as
we all know fitness is an absolute
necessity for maximum productivity
especially at a company so reliant on
office work as samsung so there are
hundreds of sports clubs and over 10
basketball courts four badminton courts
three soccer fields two baseball
diamonds a climbing wall and an olympic
size swimming pool just in case you
thought anything was missing and then
there are more nerdy things like the
memo lab which secretly tests all of
samsung's products or the 5g city a
testing ground for new cellular and
wireless technologies i can go on and on
about all the awesome stuff that the
company has done for its employees but
what i find the most impressive is what
the company does for the people that
they're not directly responsible for
philanthropy and community service
you see for nearly 60 years since the
campus was founded samsung has
maintained a strong tradition of not
only giving locals access to its
healthcare and other services but by
directly supporting them as a customer
in the form of sourcing all the food
stuff locally and that i think is what
really sets this campus apart and in my
opinion makes it the most unique one on
earth i hope you enjoyed watching
today's video and if you did be sure to
leave a like and subscribe for more with
that take care and i'll see you guys
next time